all right environmentalists are stepping
up warnings about the dangers of plastic
waste in our oceans scientists say
plastic trash goes into the marine food
chain after washes out to sea now that
means it could eventually end up on your
dinner plate recycling is only a partial
solution because as we reported Monday
and most products cannot be recycled
Janet shamlian shows us how a cutting
edge plan outside Portland Oregon may
hold the key to keeping plastic out of
the ocean this could be any recycling
center in America but what's happening
inside is different than any other plant
and could be a game-changer for the
entire industry bill Cooper is the CFO
of edgelits
a company recycling products chemically
what actually is chemical recycling so
with chemical recycling we break down
plastic to its core building blocks down
to the molecular level
unlike mechanical recycling which takes
the plastic and reforms it into a usable
pellet again in other words taking used
plastics melting them down into a liquid
and turning them back into new plastics
most plastic we toss in a recycling bin
actually can't be recycled a staggering
91 percent anything dirty or
contaminated by food usually gets sent
to a landfill we can handle meat
packaging fish packaging the level of
contamination doesn't affect our process
and that means a whopping 95 percent of
what comes in here can be reprocessed
it's one of only a handful plants doing
this in the United States here's why it
matters
a dead whale found in the Philippines
earlier this month filled with plastic
88 pounds of it another washed ashore in
Italy last week with almost 50 pounds
the world's oceans are becoming polluted
by plastic product that we can't live
without
Nick malice is with the advocacy group
Ocean Conservancy what's the impact on
marine life we know that more than 800
ocean animals are affected by plastics
in our ocean and almost every single
seabird on this planet has been found
with plastics in Scott so how do we stop
it
many experts believe that dredging the
ocean isn't pasta
the preventing what gets into it the
first place is the only real solution we
also need to look at reducing the amount
of single-use plastics that are being
produced and consumed globally some
states are trying to regulate a cleaner
environment in 2018 more than 30 bills
in nine states proposed limiting food
packaging and the use of straws most of
them failed California lawmaker Lorena
Gonzalez wants to phase out all
single-use plastics in her state by 2030
we end up eating these fish that have
Micro plastics in them and end up
digesting them into our embodies as well
plastic producers are starting to take
ownership of the problem coca-cola
recently admitted it produces 3 million
tons of plastic each year reportedly
more than 20% of the world's bottles the
company says it will create packaging
made of at least 50 percent recycled
material by 2030 in part using chemical
recycling at edgelits there's no such
thing as too much plastic the company
says almost all of it can be reused an
infinite number of times and recently
it's started processing something most
people thought couldn't be recycled
styrofoam we call this a coffee cup but
in the recycling world
it's a single-use product it usually
ends up in a landfill but not here it
will be crushed it will be densified and
eventually
not just food and drink containers but
all those giant pieces used for shipping
big screen TVs and other electronics
environmentalists might say you're
turning it back into another plastic
it's not really solving the problem
we're not turning it into something bad
we're taking a single use item and we're
making it highly usable we're making it
usable multiple times over and over and
over again a new method for recycling
amid new hope of turning the tide on
plastic in our oceans for CBS this
morning Janet shamlian Tigard Oregon got
it Janet thank you